ganz besondere frauen die beide über
sich hinauswachsen müssen olena stellen
ska ukrainische first lady direkt aus
dem krieg ist sie nach london kommt hat
sie getroffen kate prinzessin kate und
beide waren beim großen staatsbankett
mit den staats und regierungschefs wie
us präsident joe biden gestern abend vor
ort und ein berühmtes paar durfte
allerdings daran nicht teilnehmen das
wandern harry und megan die waren leider
ausgeladen schauen wir auf das große
staatsbankett wo sich alle mächtigen und
wichtigen getroffen
das größte begräbnis aller zeiten und
die ganze welt reist an
staatsoberhäupter botschafter
ausländische royals sie sind in london
um an der beerdigung von königin
elisabeth teilzunehmen hochrangige
delegation aus allen teilen der erde ob
us-präsident oder scheich botschafter
oder sie alle reisen an erweisen der
verstorbenen königin queen elizabeth der
zweite die letzte ehre am sonntagabend
gibt es dann ein großes staatsbankett im
buckingham palace auf einladung des
neuen königs charles dem dritten
der us-präsident richtet tröstende worte
an die königliche familie
unsere herzen sind bei könig charles und
seiner familie
es ist ein verlust für ein riesiges loch
hinterlässt vielleicht denken einige sie
werden nie darüber hinwegkommen aber ich
habe der könig gesagt sie wird bei ihm
seien auf jedem schritt seines weges
schieben jeder minute in jedem moment
will
london im ausnahmezustand und dann steht
das ganze land plötzlich still
[Musik]
eine schweigeminute alle machen mit auch
downing street number ten
dann geht sie ein letztes mal unter am
abend bevor die queen ihre letzte reise
antritt die sonne über westminster hall
sie sagt lebwohl königin von england
[Musik]